hi there
i'm joel and i'm going to talk about 10
ways to fizz
buzz so the reason i'm talking about
this is that i wrote a book called
tennessee's on fizzbuzz and i'm going to
give you a taste of it
you may also know me as the guy who
doesn't like notebooks and who gave a
jupiter con talk about it
or maybe from my previous book data
science from scratch or maybe from a
variety of other things
and so i assume that most of you are
familiar with fizzbuzz but
if you're not it's the following problem
print the numbers from 1 to 100
except that if the number is divisible
by 3 instead print fizz
if the number is visible by 5 instead
print buzz
if the numbers divisible by 15 instead
print fizzbuzz
so it's sometimes used as like a really
basic litmus test
for coding interviews what happened was
a few years back i wrote a blog post
called fizzbuzz in tensorflow it was the
story of someone who was insulted
at being asked fizzbuzz in an interview
and solved it as a deep learning
problem and this blog post was you know
popular as far as blog posts go
and since then i've been associated with
fizzbuzz in the mind of the public
and sometimes people tweeted me to write
books about it and then i got
quarantined
so i did now that tweet asked for a
hundred ways 100 is a lot
but i was able to come up with 10 and i
use each one as a basis for an essay
about some aspect of coding
or python or mathematics or software
engineering or design or computer
science or so on
uh and and so in this talk i don't have
enough time to go into the details it's
a very short talk
and also you know i'd like you to read
the book so i'll just introduce you to
the 10 solutions
and hopefully leave you wanting to know
more okay and so was i able to come up
with 10 solutions
that are all interesting i like to think
so uh but you know you can judge
uh and so just to remind you again the
problem is to print the numbers from one
to a hundred
except that if the number is visible a
three prime fizz divisible by five print
buzz
and if it's visible by 15 instead print
fizz buzz
and so this is the first solution 100
print statements
and so this is a solution you know in a
lot of ways it's not a good solution
but 100 percent it solves the problem as
stated
and if nothing else it really shows your
interviewer what's what
and you should never underestimate that
as uh
you know a benefit the second solution
uses if an elephant elephant else and
this is sort of the canonical solution
it's probably what your interviewer will
be expecting you to write
but you know it's order sensitive you
have to get the conditions the right
order
and it requires you to know the modulus
operator which some people uh
think is unfair and anyway if you know
the modulus operator maybe you
appreciate that there's a deeper
structure to the problem
that maybe those first two solutions
fail to take advantage of
um and so this cycle of 15 solution uh
i like a lot because it starts to hint
at that deeper structure and this
solution works all the solutions work
these are all good solutions but i like
this one it
it captures you know some of what's
really going on
and maybe you prefer a number theory if
you prefer number three there's always
euclid's
solution uh this is this is one of my
favorites actually
i'll let you stare at it for a minute to
see how elegant it is
uh it's probably not obvious how it
works um
i know it's not obvious to me looking at
it how it works
um but if you go through it it actually
does work and
and if you sort of unpack it
it's quite a beautiful solution
and you maybe you thought that
trigonometry would never be useful for
anything
but here i've used trigonometry to solve
uh fizzbuzz you can see it uses
math.cosign
and of course as a person of taste
instead of using math.pi i use math.tau
i encourage you to make the switch as
well read the manifesto
and so on so this is a nice elegant
trigonometric solution
to fizzbuzz which you probably did not
suspect admitted a trigonometric
solution
this sixth solution involves uh a big
number
uh this one is definitely the most
opaque of all the solutions
um and there's actually quite a bit
going on here
but i promise you this works and if you
spend some time studying it you can
understand how it works and why it works
and it's again
it's sort of interesting uh sort of not
up to you
so this one is another of my favorites
in fact this one might be my overall
favorite
uh it's extremely elegant uses no
numbers
other than there's a one there in a
hundred um he uses no modulus operator
no checking for divisibility
it's pure iter tools and i love it tools
so
you know stare at this uh and bask in
how elegant
inner tools makes the solution to this
problem uh it's pretty great
um so yeah this is probably my favorite
and then this one you know is really
surprising i think everyone finds this
one surprising
um this one i didn't entirely come up
with myself um i got the idea at least
from stack overflow but the code is mine
and um it uses random guessing
to solve fizbo so you can see that you
know again there's no modulus
no divisibility there's just this call
to random not choice which picks a
random number
or a random element of these possible
outputs
and surprisingly this works
uh i encourage you to try it yourself if
you don't believe me uh but i promise
it works and it's pretty interesting why
uh so check it out
and then you know matrix multiplication
is pretty popular these days so if
you're into numpy
uh here's a numpy based solution that
takes a weights matrix multiplies it by
a vector and takes the arg max and uses
that to solve it so this
again uh maybe is a little bit
surprising as to why it works or
but if you go and start the code or read
the book or work through it lima line
hopefully you'll get it um and then you
know here's the one you're waiting for
fizz buzz and tensorflow
although these days i actually work in
pie torch hence the sick
because this is actually fizzbuzz and
pie torch but you know here's how i
would approach
fizz buzz as a deep learning problem
first i define a data model to represent
a fizzbuzz
instance for training and prediction
it's got a number it's got some features
it's got a label
and it knows what class it should belong
to
we write a helper function to evaluate a
trained model so that we can make sure
our model
is is at least somewhat good and then we
use binary digits as the feature vector
um it turns out that again i can't get
into it in 10 minutes but
there are some pretty interesting
reasons why using binary digits
uh as a vector of features which allows
you to represent all numbers up to
you know 1023 uh works reasonably well
and then to do good machine learning
discipline we train on the numbers from
101 up to 10 23
and actually i could have done 10 24.
and you know
we test on one to 100 which is what we
wanted
um and then we've done good machine
learning and
you know here's just a training loop to
train the model and it sort of works
and the details of how it works are
again pretty interesting
and again speak to a much deeper
structure that this problem has
that you might not you know appreciate
if you just look at it very casually and
and solve it
using an if statement so anyway
those are my ten solutions to fizzbuzz
you know if uh
if i've made you curious uh you can get
the book for cheap at it's
fizbowsbook.com i'll see
pi data that's a coupon uh for this
conference
or you know if you don't want to buy the
book or read the book or anything you
just want to see these solutions they're
all on github
for free you know just go to github.com
dwellersfizbuzz
and you can find them there and play
with them yourselves you know don't
forget about data science from scratch
the second edition which came out in
2019 is very very good
um find me on twitter at joel groose
i'll tweet out these slides and so you
can find them there if you want to look
at them
and you know finally check out my rarely
updated blog
at uh joelgroose.com so thanks for
uh thanks for coming and thanks for
listening and uh enjoy
the rest of the conference and and i
guess you can ask questions in the q a
for the rest of this time so thanks
again and take care